rakio hussein ahmed says when she
planted her last handful of seeds on her
farm rain never came
with no food left she started to make
her way here somalia's capital mogadishu
with her four children their journey
began on the back of a truck
then things got worse
the truck driver said this is my last
stop you can continue on your own to
mogadishu we sat down under a tree my
two babies were in bad condition because
of hunger and thirst then all of the
sudden i found they had white eyes they
had died there was a lady living there
who helped me to bury them by the
roadside
rakio and her two surviving children are
among a rapidly growing number of people
who are now staying in camps like this
on the outskirts of the city
most of the people here have walked for
more than a week to get here they
carried whatever they could tarpaulins
and sheets that's what they've made
their shelters out of there more than a
thousand people living in this
settlement and all of these shelters
have sprung up within the last four
weeks where they've come from the
situation's been deteriorating and the
humanitarian agencies say it's about to
get much worse
most of them have come from the southern
part of somalia where they depended on
farming and herding livestock until the
last three rainy seasons failed crops
withered and animals died
here they're surviving on one meal a day
however mohammed osman was one of the
first to arrive
she's a community leader she's been
trying to find help with little success
the situation around here is extremely
difficult people are hungry and in poor
house people don't even have shelter
every time a car passes here people
think that somebody is coming to give
them food
it's a similar story all around the
outskirts of mogadishu
the un says more than 60 000 people have
arrived here in the last four months and
across the country more than half a
million people have been displaced by
the drought
humanitarian organizations say they only
have three percent of the funds needed
to help them the solution is for
everyone to act fast
we need more fund we need more attention
to the drought we need
support from the donor agencies from
donor countries
to the somali people that's what we need
now
meanwhile somalia's government is
entangled in an ongoing and fraught
electoral process
much of the world's attention is focused
on the war in ukraine
people here have been left
destitute they're waiting and wondering
if anyone will come to help
malcolm webb al jazeera mogadishu
somalia